let's do another question here this one
is from Facebook Robin has a question
for us why do auto insurance companies
check your credit report before deciding
how much you should pay them I used to
have excellent credit but now that I
have nothing on there good or bad they
now see me as a risk one thing that the
Ramsey team has taught me really well is
that a credit score is not a credit
score it is a debt score George can you
talk about why credit scores don't
really matter yeah this is probably the
most one of the most controversial takes
in the book and I have the first
chapters on credit scores because I
truly feel like it's the gateway drug to
all other types of debt because think
about it how do you get a credit score
well you have to open some kind of line
of credit some kind of account how do
you increase your credit score well you
take on debt and you pay it off the
exact way they want you to that's how it
increases and once it increases what do
you do what do you get you get access to
more debt and if you don't understand
how crazy that is then you need to get a
pulse check and so the idea of a credit
score is that it tells you how good you
are at debt management not money
management and that was a GameChanger
for me you can play the credit score
game perfectly and have nothing in the
bank and no wealth to show for it you
can have an 800 credit score and make
$155,000 a year if you've played the
game and manipulated the pieces
appropriately yeah can we talk about
some of the myths around that though I
can't buy a house without a credit score
I can't get an apartment without a
credit score get auto insurance talk
about those and what are there ways
around that or are some people stuck if
they have a bad credit score yeah so I
walk through every single objection I've
heard every single reason that people
want to hang on with their credit score
in the book and I walk them through it
systematically with step by step here's
exactly how to rent a car without a
credit score and with a debit card
here's exactly what it means for your
insurance rates when you don't have a
credit score and yes your credit score
is a factor when it comes to insurance
they have an insurance score that they
use but there's so many other ways to
get a good insurance rate outside of
having a credit score one is paying all
of your bills on time two is combining
other types of insurance like your Auto
and homeowners you get a discount for
that so I still get great rates on
insurance and the other thing people
don't realize is that you need to be
shopping with an independent insurance
broker not your college buddy who works
for State Farm who you've used for 20
years you're probably getting ripped off
there so I use Xander insurance which
has been a partner with Ramsey for years
now and so they shop a bunch of
different companies companies I've never
heard of that are A+ rated to get the
best rate at the best price and and best
coverage so that's one way to do it when
it comes to renting I we just did a
YouTube episode where I called
Apartments all over the country and I
said hey I don't have a credit score can
I still apply with you guys can I still
rent and unequivocally they were like
yeah there just might be a slightly
higher deposit and we'll need proof of
income and a criminal background check
oh okay that was easy well let's pause
on that for a second so you're pointing
out you're making an important
distinction that I think most people
don't think about you're saying I don't
have a credit score which is appreciably
different from I have a bad credit score
right abely can you maybe show the
distinction there yes low or bad credit
scores mean you have mismanaged money
you haven't paid on time there's a
delinquent account sitting out there and
that can and will hurt you financially
and so the key distinction here is if
you are following the Ramsey plan you
are aggressively paying off your
Consumer Debt once you do that and
you've closed every credit card account
everything is gone 6 to 12 months later
your credit score will become
indeterminable it doesn't necessarily go
to zero we say zero credit score it just
disappears it sort of just falls off the
map once it hits a certain threshold and
that's what happened to me and then I
went well I got to buy a house and so
I've heard about this process called
manual underwriting it's old timey they
don't use Ai and pull your credit score
a real person looks at your actual tax
returns and income and utility bills and
goes we're going to qualify George for a
more mortgage which by the way they do
that anyway even if you have an
outstanding credit score you can't go to
a bank and just say hey look my credit
score is 800 and they're like oh we're
not going to worry about how much money
you make then here's a billion dollar
house have fun no they're still going to
figure out can you okay you have a good
credit score R it's all about risk yes
and so do you make enough money in order
to pay for this thing we're giving you
the money
for yeah I think part of the challenge
here is the difficulty involved with
develop a vocabulary for an alternative
you know when when you live in a culture
where everything is just done a certain
way it really feels like well I can't
opt out because we just don't know these
things about how to do it elsewhere it's
like when when I was running the
apprenticeship program with prais it's
like there were lots of people that
wanted to opt out of college but they
had no concept of what they could do
it's only when they understood well here
are the apprenticeship options here are
the other things that you can do that
they're able to exercise the courage to
say no to what they they've been wanting
to say no to for a very long time this
is why I appreciate uh the work that
you're doing you're showing people hey
here's what a life of no to the system
looks like because if you don't give
them that they'll just feel guilty that
they're saying yes to these things we
criticize but they won't have an
alternative way so having a great credit
score as a byproduct is one thing but
gaming the system in order to improve
your credit score just so you can get
into more debt actually becomes a
problem the biggest problem is yes
having a poor or low credit score
because that will exclude you from
certain places even if you have
sufficient income but you're just
terrible at making payments on things
well guess what I probably if I'm the
bank I don't want to loan you any money
and even if I'm a landlord if I know
that you have really terrible credit
what does that tell me oh this guy's
never going to pay his rent on he's a
risky borrower exctly but when I show up
to the mortgage lender and I go I don't
have a credit score I have zero debt to
my name I have a a nice sizable down
payment and then they look at my income
they go okay here's the mortgage and I
got a great rate I got a great interest
rate this was back in 2019 and we
aggressively paid off the house and now
I don't worry about interest rates
anymore I don't worry about what my
credit score is I don't have to keep up
with it with a fancy app and it's given
me Great Piece to just unplug from the
system in another way and deprogram all
of the myths that I learned I hope you
enjoyed that highlight from the
minimalist private podcast if you'd like
another highlight check out this video
if you'd like to watch the minimal
episode check out this video or if you'd
like to dive deep into full episodes of
the minist private podcast head on over
to patreon the link is in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free